control the various stock of days by
mitali buffer and he's she's going to
tell us about unique games and expansion
so take it away mitali
thanks everyone for coming
talk about two joints one is with Boaz
pravesh Leela and David and then another
one which is a follow-up door
okay so let's define unique games
uh we look at the special class called a
fine uni games in which you're given n
variables and two's past linear
equations module okay and each equation
is of the following form
so uh the obvious question to ask now is
how do you solve this linear equation a
linear system when it is satisfiable and
we know how to do it do this by caution
elimination but in fact in this case
there's a much simpler algorithm uh you
just do propagation so create the
following graph where you put in a
Vertex for every variable and an edge
for every constraint uh label the edges
by the right hand sides and then assign
the first variable to be 0 and propagate
this value to the second variable and so
on
until you have a solution in K to the N
to all the vertices
and from now on we'll think of this
equivalent graph view uh where we create
different unique Games instances on
graphs by varying The Edge labels
so what if I tweak the problem and gave
you a linear system in which only 90
equations are satisfiable
can we find a 90 satisfying assignment
or even just a one percent satisfying
assignment
so note that a random assignment
satisfies One by K fraction of the
equations
and here we think of K as really really
large so this is not good enough
so in fact in 2002 code conjectured that
this problem is hard so given 90
satisfiable unique games finding a one
percent satisfying solution is not
possible efficiently
and uh this turned out to have really
nice consequences to hardness of
approximation where in most case many
cases we got optimal hardness of
approximation results
and for other problems uh these are the
best known results and they are not
known under NP not equals B
so what is known about unique games
the history is really like a game
between hardness and algorithms
as soon as it was proposed there were
various algorithms that got uh alphabet
dependent guarantees or like uh
different
um guarantees depending on the size of
the graph but they were not able to
refute the conjecture
and then it was shown that in fact
unique games is easy on random instances
so where you have a random graph or an
expanded graph and you vary The Edge
labels
and in fact it even had non-trivial sub
exponential time algorithms so note that
both these uh algorithms are kind of in
contrast to heart problems such as
threesat where we believe uh such
algorithm should not exist
and in contrast
um it was shown to be hard on small set
expanders under a stronger conjecture
known as the small set expansion
hypothesis which I will get to very soon
and to culminate these results uh uni
games were shown to be hard when when
you have like a 49 versus one percent uh
instance
um and uh yeah so okay and uh so all
these algorithms are based on uh
rounding semi-definite programming
relaxations
uh and a specific uh once called sum of
squares
and today I will tell you about our
algorithms that uh
um expand the class of graphs on which
unique games is easy while building new
rounding techniques for some of squares
and I will focus on these two complexity
results
so these are our results for uni games
and uh you don't need to know what these
classes of graphs are and I will soon
because I will soon Define them
so now let me dive into our results or
any questions before that
it's possible
protested using games like if you're
subtracting it like this then you won't
put any game like what's the motivating
yeah that that is one goal and the goal
is also to find hard instances
oh yeah I will talk a bit about that
again
you know
okay so so before telling you about our
results uh let me tell you about this
family of graphs
um where the vertex that we've seen this
a lot in uh the program the vertex set
is are sized subsets of M
and you have an edge between two
vertices if they have uh if they
intersect in at least T elements and
this class of graphs is nice because uh
they exhibit all these properties for
various regimes of MTN r
so you don't need to remember what these
graphs are but uh like this is just to
give an example of all the class all the
graphs you will be talking about
okay so let's start with uni games on
expanders
so we all know what expansion is
and now I'll Define uh think of x uh
expanders
where um G is an expander if all sets of
size at most point it n have expansion
at least 0.2
this is a bit non-standard but uh yeah I
could have made this constant a bit
smaller but I decided to stick with the
most optimal constant
um okay so the earliest works showed
that we have polynomial time algorithms
for Unique games on expanders
so let me tell you uh let me like now
give you a different analysis for this
algorithm
when we have a fine unique Games
instances
so our key observation is that uh for ug
instances of expanders
uh any two assignments that satisfy 90
of the edges must be equal up to shift
on 80 percent of the vertices
so in some sense this is a kind of
uniqueness of the solution space because
up to uh there is one true solution and
every other solution is a perturbation
of this solution in 20 of the vertices
so let's try to prove this uh Lemma
and before that just this is a reminder
and uh note that two assignments X and X
Plus s modulo k satisfy the exact same
set of edges so we'll think of them as
essentially equivalent
okay
okay so let's try to prove this Lemma
and in fact the proof is not that hard
so create the following partition of the
vertices where for each uh
um for in each component so in the
zeroth component you put in all the
vertices I where x equals X so where x i
equals x i Prime module okay
yeah so we fix two solutions that
satisfy 90 of the edges and we want to
show that they must be equal in 80 of
the vertices
so we have fixed two solutions and in
the first component we put in all the
vertices uh where x equals x i Prime
module okay
and then in the second component we put
it all the vertices where they are
different up to one module okay and so
on
and now the main observation is that any
Crossing H any of these orange edges
cannot be satisfied by both the
assignments x and x Prime
so let's look at this Edge so we have
that uh on this Edge you can just
subtract both the equations to get that
X1 minus X2 if if it was equal to a12
then uh x 1 Prime minus X2 Prime cannot
be equal to a one two
so now we can use the fact that x and x
Prime both satisfy 90 of the edges
uh to get that there can only be 20
Crossing edges
at this point uh okay so a prairie each
of these components could have been n by
K in size
oh and this is much smaller than 0.810
but now we can use the expansion in the
graph
to say that at least one component must
be of large size otherwise uh you would
have at least 20 Crossing interest
so we get let's say this component was
large so we basically get that x and x
Prime are equal on 80 of the vertices
okay so uh let's see why this uniqueness
of the solution space is even useful for
algorithms
and before that let me tell you about
sum of squares
so the sum of 12 hierarchy is a powerful
meta algorithm
um based on semi definite programming
and uh it's a hierarchy of sdp is
created by degree where each uh each
level takes time n to the D
and usually given a given your
optimization problem it's easy to write
the relaxation but uh it's hard to round
the relaxation to a true solution
so uh in
um so and sum of squares captures many
important algorithms like linear
programming and spectral methods
so some of squares has been uh pretty
successful in the average case
uh and especially for robust statistics
um and most of these proofs are actually
based on uniqueness in the solution
space and in fact a very strong type of
uniqueness where sometimes you even have
just one solution
for example if you thought of the
planted Creek problem uh you have one
planted leak and in the in a random
graph you want to distinguish it from
yeah and you don't have any other Peaks
so these algorithms uh are based on kind
of taking this proof of uniqueness and
converting them into an algorithm
but for worst case optimization very
less is known
and this is mostly because uniqueness is
too much to expect
so what we do is to relax this to some
kind of weak uniqueness or weak
correlations between Solutions
foreign
we can show it to hold for some worst
case problems but uh we need some new
rounding techniques and Analysis
so now we have this intermediate
uniqueness where uh
um two solutions must be equal on a lot
of the vertices so 80
but still not all
and now we can uh use the rounding on
degree two sum of squares to get a
solution
now let me tell you a bit about the
rounding and uh before that let's see
the distribution view So Yesterday Max
gave a vector view of that let's forget
about that
think of the degree D summer squares
relaxation as giving you a distribution
uh the degree D moments of a
distribution over 90 valued assignments
to your um
to your instance so what do I mean by
this uh this just means that there
exists some distribution out there uh
which is supported over
um
90 satisfying assignments and you're
given a local statistics of that
distribution things like what's the
probability X1 equals zero and then uh
X1 and X2 equals 0 comma 1 whatever up
to up to D variables at a time
and this is not actually that but let's
just think of it like that today
okay so now uh let's see what the
algorithm is so now we want to uh given
the degree two moments of a true
distribution we want to actually produce
a solution
that satisfies uh 50 of the constraints
so actually our algorithm is pretty
simple uh what you can do is first
condition the distribution uh over the
value of a random vertex let's say uh
random vertex V equal to
um 0
and then once you have conditioned it
you can independently sample from the
marginals for the other vertices
oh and this actually depends only on
degree two moments
because
um the second step is you can calculate
the marginals of all the vertices uh the
condition marginals by just looking at
the original degree two marginals
so any questions about this
so let's see why this works
so now we can we will actually use this
observation to convert it into an
algorithm
so firstly uh this is
firstly if two every two assignments
that satisfy a lot of the edges agree
then of course if you have a
distribution of a satisfying assignments
and you sample two of them they will
also be equal up to shift
this is just like an obvious fact
and now uh imagine if in fact we had uh
that they agree up to 100 of the
vertices then what our distribution
would be it would just be x x
um some assignment X and it shifts so X
X Plus 1 up to X Plus K module okay X
Plus K minus
and then uh it's easy to see why this
would work because when we condition the
distribution over one random vertex
uh your assignment will be fixed and
independent sampling will just sample
from a fixed value for every vertex
and actually this uh this kind of
intuition can be made more robust and
even if you're given equality up to only
80 percent of the vertices after
conditioning the distribution you can
show that
um uh you basically fix most of the
vertices up to some variance
so let me give you a H some idea why it
works
so we consider this expression so this
is just expectation of X and X Prime
drawn independently from the
distribution
and this inside quantity is like the sum
of squares of
the parts that the component sizes that
we earlier had
so for example we proved that one of
these parts is at least pointed sized
I've just written it as an indicator
uh so we have that this quantity is at
least 0.8 squared
and we can actually rearrange this
quantity this is a strict uh like an
equality so
um if I gave you two minutes you would
be able to rearrange this to get this
expression here
and now we can see that because we have
two independent samples and an indicator
variable uh this becomes the Collision
probability of the random variable X U
minus X
well and in fact because we have
symmetry in the solution space this is
also the Collision probability of XU
conditioned on uh the a random vertex XV
equals zero
so what we are saying is that after
conditioning the Collision probability
is close to one
so you are basically fixing the vertices
up to this uh diff like 1 minus 0.8
squared variance
and uh we can you can use some simple
inequalities should show that the round
this is at most the rounded Value Plus
one minus the True Value and we know one
minus the true value is 10 percent
so you can rearrange to get that the
rounded value is at least 50 percent
so any questions about this
I guess it's too fast to follow like
this but
your condition on
X1 XV whole Square U and B are a random
edge of the Unicorn oh sorry so this
this expectation is over random vertices
yes
so actually I made the square into an
expectation so okay yeah
so that is 50 something was there so so
this 50 percent is an arbitrary number
but uh
uh
if you actually made this thing 50 then
this analysis voting work
s um
oh yeah okay this okay this is a random
so this is the first step
wait so the distribution that you get
from the SOS algorithm the expected
value is 90 right not or is it like
every single thing in the distribution
yeah yeah so this is this is actually
like okay the intuition I gave was for
uh sampling it but this thing is going
to be uh the expected value when you
actually look at it like when you do
this inequality here you're going to get
an accepted value over the distribution
and we know that the expected value is
actually the True Value
because it's an STP
so if 90 was the one minus Epsilon
expansion was good enough you would be
getting like one now through that seven
instead of fifty percent
like do you
yeah we're losing the root but yeah
um yes I'm just giving an address of the
previous episodes
yeah so then this is exactly one you
would get back one
okay so let's try to push this idea to a
larger class of graphs and let's go to
small set expanders so small set
expanders are graphs where only small
sets expand so we have sets of size at
most uh 10 percent have expansion at
least 0.2
and now we can ask for Unique games uh
ug algorithms over small set expanders
and let's try to do the previous let's
try to follow the previous strategy for
algorithms
so we can just do the same we can create
the same picture from before uh
uh like say that all these edges are
violated etc etc but right now but now
we can use the small set expansion of
the graph
to say that because there are only few
Crossing edges uh one of the components
must be large
but at this point we will only get that
it's large uh it's one percent we won't
get 0.8 fraction
and now we can see whether we can use
this observation to get an algorithm
so can we get uh early time algorithms
for
ug over SSE so turns out that this is in
fact hard under small set expansion
hypothesis
so what does the what does this
conjecture say
it says that checking if a graph is a
small set expander is NP hard
so uh the raghav in the asteroider
result basically says that solving this
unique games problem over it should also
be hard
so but what if we relax to graph where
checking uh this property is easy
and uh this is what we do
so we get algorithms for Unique Games
instances over these checkable sponsored
expanders
and it turns out that in fact all the
graphs we know of are also uh checkable
and this is because the way we prove uh
that they are small set expanders the
proof itself gives us this uh
checkability property
and all the proofs we've seen in the
um just to give you an idea all the
proofs that we've seen so far are
checkable uh probably not the stochastic
calculus
but yeah
so now we can use this uh checkability
property but now around a higher degree
uh sum of squares relaxation to get a
solution
now let me tell you a bit about the
rounding
yes that's a good question why is
checkability important here so if you
know that if you've got a more promise
that you have a craft as a sponsored
expanded you won't be able to solve this
in possible time like you really need to
know to have an algorithm you need to
know how to check the unique
um yeah
for the expanded case you're talking
about you don't need to check if it's an
expanded for it to work oh yeah so there
actually we use the fact that um chica's
inequality always gives us this
checkability
oh
yeah so whenever it's an expander you
have like the easy direction of
trigger's inequality gives us
so and yeah the point there is to that
sum of squares has to know about the
expansion
so yeah so the proof that we learned
thank you
okay so we can again try to do the same
analysis of this algorithm
but now the issue is that we only have
0.01 here
0.01 squared here
and whereas this one minus 2 value is
something like 0.1 so this inequality
this gives you a totally uh like stupid
bound on the rounding value
and this is completely useless
and intuitively this is because uh
when you say that two assignments are
equal in one percent of the vertices
these vertices could be the ones where X
and X Prime violate all the edges
because we know that ten percent of the
edges are violated so these vertices
could have all the violated edges
touching them and this is not
this is not something useful in that
case
so now what we need to do is that we
need to show that x and x Prime actually
agree in one percent vertices that also
have high value
and then we need to like generalize uh
like kind of build upon this analysis
to round to show that this algorithm
works
and this process actually requires
higher degree moments and higher degree
Asos
okay so I won't tell you about this but
uh let me go to a larger class of graphs
um globally hyperconductive graphs
okay so this is a totally unoriginal uh
so uh now uh what if your graph had
small non-expanding sets
um can we still
uh yeah so this is something we've
already seen um teen times
and
this result shows that this particular
noisy Johnson graph is a sausage so
there exists a small
um
collection of small canonical
non-expanding sets in this graph such
that every non-expanding set such as
this s must be close to a union of
canonical sets
so we have that s must be basically the
uh a union so the only way to form these
sets is by taking unions of the bis
so now we again have this picture for
the tenth time
and
uh in fact this this claim is no longer
true
so we can even providely show that a
weak uniqueness fails so
two assignments x and x Prime uh that
satisfy most of the edges might not
agree in one percent of the vertices
but at this point uh we can use global
hyperconductivity
to say that this partition because it is
non-expanding it must be of this form
Okay so
now uh we have so how should we use this
picture now
so now what this says is that for every
two assignments x and x Prime
satisfying a lot of the edges there
exists many canonical sets bis
such that x and x Prime are equal uh in
one percent of the vertices of bi
so here I'm just taking put taking all
of these sets and that's why I have many
and uh
inside them you can see that they
completely lie inside the partition so
that that's why x and x Prime are equal
on them
okay so uh because we have this for all
assignments we can we also have this for
distributions over assignments
and now uh what you can do is that given
a distribution you can exchange the
quantifier so given a distribution you
know that for every two x and x Prime
sampled from them you get that there are
many canonical non-expanding sets for
that x and x Prime so you can exchange
the quantifiers to get that for a fixed
uh non-expanding set B
with large probability uh over x and x
Prime they are equal in one percent of
the vertices
and this in some sense says that for a
fixed uh set b
um you have only a few Solutions on B
this is because otherwise you wouldn't
have such you you kind of have only 10
to the 10 Solutions
so if you apply the small set expansion
analysis with some more care you can
actually get uh this valued solution
but this is not good enough because in
general this value could actually depend
on the alphabet size uh
um
in the yeah when when you take Johnson
graphs in particular parameter regimes
this would depend on the alphabet size
and
and these are the Johnson graphs that we
are interested in
yeah so this is something this is
something like uh K to the minus 10.
foreign
okay so let's see how to round this
okay so the obvious uh solution to round
this would be to condition the
distribution uh the D cross D
distribution over x and x Prime
on the events that
um
the assignments are equal on this fixed
set B
and then once we condition uh we would
have just by uh just by the just by
definition we would have that x and x
Prime are equal up to one percent on B
and then we can apply the small cell
expansion analysis from before
so any questions about this
okay so uh the issue is that
uh conditioning actually destroys the
independence between x and x Prime
so
um
in particular the event you conditioned
on could just be x equals x Prime for
example
and then by definition x and x Prime are
correlated
uh so you run into this uh loop where
you want to so initially recall that we
want to pick two random assignments
um from the distribution and say that
they are correlated and that's why the
original distribution had large
Collision probability
but after you condition they could
literally be equal and uh that um
the two solutions being correlated does
not tell us anything about the original
Collision probability
okay so uh our main fix is to
pre-process this distribution
D cross d uh so that even after
conditioning
on high probability events
most of the vertices XU most of the
pairs pairs of random variables
remain independent
so
yeah this is some this is just some
level Lemma about uh distributions
so any questions about this
is
explicit list of uh
so so uh basically this proof of
uniqueness always uses checkability
which I was hiding
yeah
yeah so uh I can tell you a bit about
what this pre-processing is
um
so for example if the event e uh you
conditioned on set a lot of the vertices
we kind of
because you you condition only on uh
one by ten to the 10 property events it
cannot set many of the vertices equal it
cannot set like n vertices to be equal
unless they were already equal to begin
with unless your uh distribution was
literally one assignment supported over
one assignment in that case uh
conditioning will obviously uh set you
can condition on a half probability
event and create correlations between x
and x Prime
so the idea is to remove the original
correlations that existed in d uh by
doing some kind of global correlation or
reduction
and then then whenever we condition
um we retain pairwise Independence
okay so then we can use this uh
um all this Machinery to get uh
one percent satisfying solution
okay and um the we've already seen that
many graphs satisfy this uh this kind of
property in particular Grassman and
noisy works on the Johnson and high
dimensional expanders
oh
yeah so it requires some work but mostly
uh the intuition is that they only use
so all these uh proofs are like
polynomial inequalities like for example
bonami's llama and uh they only use of
obvious facts such as koshy shots and
holders
foreign
yeah so
so DSM distribution outputted by the
um
and then we can we can do whatever we
want on it and then output a solution
so what we do is do this Global
correlation reduction
This Global correlation reduction is
like a particular operation you
basically condition on a lot of vertices
until the remaining distribution has no
no dependencies like X U and XV are
almost pairwise independent
yeah and then we run the previous
analysis on
okay
here
so now what about uh non-globely hyper
contracted graphs in particular let's
say the non the Johnson graph in this
regime where it's not globally hyper
contractors
so here we actually think that we should
not have algorithms and that's because
of this uh
um 49 versus one percent hardness result
um so this is because uh these hard
instances
are of this form so they are something
like the Johnson graph
in this parameter regime composed with
the Craftsman graph
and our algorithms work even though I
did not show you they work in this 49
regime also
so
uh basically at a high level this tells
us that this graph is easy so this graph
must be hard
um and uh uh a caveat with this thing is
um yeah so this is like he heard and a
small I think a small caveat is that our
algorithms work for a fine unique games
and this reduction produces uh General
unique games
and if we ran the reduction from
well-known reduction from General uni
games to a fine unique games it
um yeah so we are not sure whether it
destroys This Global hyperconductivity
property or not
so uh we are so we know already that
like uh the algorithms
um there are expander algorithms from
previous works over General uni games
and we think that I think even the
a small set expander algorithms work
work over General uni games by just
running the reduction but for these
globally hyper-contractive graphs we
might destroy the property although we
think uh it should hold for General
learning games
foreign
so up to that this is kind of some
evidence that uh this Johnson graph in
this parameter regime should be hard for
Unique games
okay oh and this is a summary
and now let me conclude with some future
directions
so uh one of the main open questions is
to get hard instances for Unique games
or integrality gaps
so uh on the Johnson okay this is I
think this is cut out here but uh here I
had 49 satisfiable
oh okay
yeah so on the Johnson graphs in this 49
satisfiable regime uh when we look at
expanders and small set expanders Etc
um these things are easy uh because of
algorithms and this is likely hard
because of the reduction
uh but in the 99 regime our algorithm
still stops working in this same regime
of parameters
so a natural question to ask is whether
we can build integrality gaps using the
Johnson graph
and uh
then I showed you some rounding
techniques where we take proofs of
uniqueness into uh and get a solution
so it's natural to ask what are the
other optimization problems with such
uniqueness properties and by uniqueness
here I again mean that where uh two
solutions to the problem must be
correlated in let's say a small constant
fraction and not really like 90 percent
and uh Even in our algorithms most of
the work goes in showing such uniqueness
properties so
yeah it's it would be nice to see what
other problems have these properties
so uh this is the picture of the hard
optimization problems from earlier uh we
have a lot of algorithms now for Unique
games but all these other algor all
these other problems we basically know
only one kind of only one algorithm
which is taking the degree to sdp and
running some kind of simple rounding on
it
so uh
uh basically we it would be nice to see
if any of these techniques uh give new
algorithms for these Downstream problems
for example can you build better sub
exponential time algorithms for any of
these problems like Max cut
or can you bridge the gap between
hardness and algorithms for these
problems where there is a huge gap
thanks
foreign
[Music]
and then your
um you connect two edges if they differ
in
your chain to connect to edges you
change uh One by K fraction of the
coordinate so you change very few
coordinates
also basically where the noise is
dependent on the alphabet size
any more questions
okay so let's make Italy again
[Applause]
we'll see you at the moment